Let's look at a way we might try to calculate this.
We need to know the number of possible states that this computer could go through
in order to know whether or not we could get to a state we've already been to
in a reasonable amount of time.
How many states are there?
Each bit can be in 1 of 2 states, either 1 or 0.
There are 8 bits per byte, that's 2^8 states, per byte.
We have a 1,024 bytes in our memory. We have a kilobyte of memory.
That gives us 2^8^1,024 power, which is 10^2466.
This is a huge number already. This is just the possible states in our memory.
How many can we go through in a year?
We take 10 billion steps per second.
So 10 billion steps per second is 10^9 steps per second.
Now how many seconds in a year?
This is just multiplying by 60 seconds in a minute, times 60 minutes in an hour,
times 24 hours in a day, times 365.25 days in a year.
This equals 10^17.5 states that we can calculate in a year.
That means that really what we want to do is take 10^2466 states
and divide by this 1 year/10^17.5 states.
This gives us 10^2448.5 years.
This is an insanely huge number.
This is for a computer that only has a kilobyte of total memory.
The sheer number of states that we can be in, even in such a small memory
and especially in a larger memory like you would see in a computer today,
is just so massive that calculating decidability in this fashion isn't actually feasible.
This is why we still really care whether our problem is undecidable theoretically or not.